look let's get stuck into the first um
piece that I wanted to to discuss which
is the recent well at least your Tweet
as a response to the recent uh marriage
Special by Jordan Peterson which mind
you I haven't watched yet but uh I think
I could knowing Jordan's work quite well
um and following your work I could kind
of make out you know what he said so
talking through you know what you
thought was
you know maybe we'll start with the
benefit of that what do you think was
good about that special and then what
are the things you feel were um were you
know not accurately or or well discussed
I well I think overall the entire
three-part series wasn't well discussed
to set guys up properly for the notion
of marriage today especially in the west
um overall I like Jordan I think he's
done a good job I especially appreciate
the way he handles the wolf mob and you
know the rabbit left sort of like um
interviews and conversations I think
he's great at that but his whole
strategy with the three-part series on
daily wire on marriage is really just
man up don't be a wimp
um just get married uh negotiate between
yourselves but it's got It's got more
holes in a block of Swiss cheese if I'm
being honest and that and that's the
point of that Twitter thread and I also
did a uh podcast episode breaking down
everything that I came across and what I
thought of it and I just kind of fed
back on all the points there so
um I mean there's quite a few what do
you want to start with
well look let's pull on
let's say what do you think of the top
three uh holes in the Swiss cheese here
that um that he
yeah so one of the most glaring problems
that I saw with his push for guys to
just man up and get married was it
relies on a lot of negotiation
um he's he seems to think or comes from
an era where
um men and women are equally accountable
and will take ownership in equal regards
they're both committed he doesn't take
into account a lot of the problems that
are that are out there today which I'll
get into in just a sec but like the real
problem is he's basically suggesting
that men and women can sit down and
negotiate all of their differences right
down to where the scissors go in the
appliance drawer and that might have
worked in his marriage but I don't think
the reality of the world today would
work for most men and even though men
are more apt to want to take ownership I
think especially if they're followers or
listeners of his work
um he doesn't have a lot of female
followers from what I understand and
women aren't particular interested or
good at taking ownership for things that
go on in their life you know men are
more disposable women are more protected
women are always forgiven men are always
blamed like there are differences
between the Sexes and I don't think that
he gives an honest breakdown of those
differences even though he does talk
about some differences but he doesn't
get down to like the nitty-gritty stuff
that I really get into especially with
the chapter in my book on why smart men
don't marry like I really break it down
in depth there
I think
so one area I think I would uh strongly
agree with you on so I'm a Avid Avid
Avid student of history and if you look
at
most of History the there wasn't a
negotiation between the husband and the
wife
um right
negotiation uh basically implies that
you're you know two people are coming to
the table uh with either equal power
equal status and you know I think you
discussed this quite well in your book
but
women naturally seek a higher status man
and the fact that you're negotiating
with your man uh implies that you're of
the same status which is [__]
backwards it's starting from the wrong
place in the first place correct um one
of the things he said I've just opened
up the Tweet uh tweet is that he he
doesn't like the idea of a male-led
marriage
um essentially at the head of the
household he didn't use his exact words
but he calls the idea of not using a
negotiation between the husband and wife
tyranny and slavery and advocates for
equality and negotiation down to every
single detail which is absurd I mean
like the most successful marriages that
I've known you know that have been
together for 20 25 30 years
um again you know my demographic is
slightly different because most of my
friends are mostly entrepreneurs
successful leaders out there but they
use words like you know Blue Jobs and
pink jobs right like I'm like I'm the
guy you know I'm the entrepreneur I'm
running the business she runs a
household I'm not that concern where you
know with things like where the scissors
go on the appliance store they go where
she wants to put them but at the same
time you know they also have boundaries
too where they don't have all of their
stuff sequestered to some ridiculous
corner of the house like a man cave
where the entire house is all pink Fufu
and flowers and you know curtains and
chandeliers and stuff like that that
women would tend to overly decorate with
many houses they still have some
manliness to the house right
um but there's a lot of guys out there
that have man caves in my you know my
position on that is you're a [__] I
mean if you if you buy a house and you
surrender the entire house to a woman
then like how is that your house right
if she forces you to put all of your
stuff in some dark corner of the
basement or in the garage
yeah yeah you you like her [__] child
in that case like an overgrown child
you're an accessory tour life through
the ATM that pays for everything so that
she can you know milk it to put all the
stuff all Fufu and fruffy you know
throughout the house totally okay so
Point number one is the negotiation is a
ridiculous concept between men and women
what do you think is the second big
swiss cheese hole
um
you know he says he says also that you
just can't love a woman
right which I think is [__] I mean
I've got a girlfriend I love her to bits
you know we have a great relationship
you know we've been together for quite a
while now
um but but he claims that for you to
love a woman that you need to stand up
in front of your whole community and
bind yourself to that commitment and if
you don't do it he'll call you shallow
if you try to avoid that there was
there's a bunch of other disparaging
words that he used as well to men that
try to avoid
um the risks of marriage he used foolish
juvenile short-sighted hedonistic
nihilistic cynical Psychopathic
impulsive promiscuous pathetic 40 year
old Frat Boys Scoundrels and half-wits
so I I guess I'm all of those things
because I've chosen not to expose my
wealth or my life to the risks of family
law because he just completely overlooks
the fact that that when you get married
in the west if you get married in Canada
or many of the states uh down in the U.S
in the UK you know for example many
places in Australia same thing yeah
Australia New Zealand
um if if it doesn't work out which seven
to ten years down the road about 50
percent of the time it doesn't you have
to untie the knot and women initiate
that about 80 percent of the time
um all of those nasty words that he's
calling you uh won't matter at all
because you're going to lose half of
your stuff in some cases in Australia I
know that some some men have lost more
than half of their stuff and quite often
are alienated from their own children
and they just watch their wealth flow
from their Investments to her while she
separates him from his kids so there's
no there's no real like it's a lot of
shaming language like if you don't wipe
her up then you're a [__] you're not a
man there's no hey you know things have
changed in the west and you might want
to consider these things or vet women
properly in this sense like one of the
most simplest vetting tools that guys
can use is don't marry a promiscuous
woman like I'm not against having kids
I'm not against you know being with
women the problem is is that marriage is
very very high risk and low reward for
men especially successful men and it's
low risk and high reward for women
especially when they marry across and up
the socioeconomic scale which 95 of the
time they do there's always that you
know there's always that one person
that's going to come and saying well I'm
a stay-at-home dad and my wife goes to
work and it works out fine for us sure
okay but does she still suck you
enthusiastically or are you just you
know projecting your your story because
the vast majority of women that end up
in a scenario where they marry a a guy
that that doesn't bring home the bacon
that they do far better than they're not
interested in that man right they
generally go out and have affairs right
so okay I want to pull on those on that
thread a little bit so
when you say that the the marriage
component so so the legalization by the
state
um is basically a bad practical step
because it opens you up uh from a legal
perspective
isn't the law written these days such
that even if you just uh live with a
woman like where you're not married on
paper Etc yeah she still has claim okay
correct correct so you know here here
where I live common law is two years uh
there's other places where it could be
anywhere from two to seven years but
common law is something that you have to
be aware of and you have to consider
um if you're going to invite a woman
into your life and to live with you
because here if I live with a woman for
two years in a day the government
considers us married and if we were to
part ways and you know leave
um she would be entitled to half my
stuff right
um would she take it I don't know but if
you can enrich yourself and make
millions of dollars by telling a guy to
pound sand and and leave and if you're
mad at them maybe cheated on you or
something like that you're and you're
really upset well Hell hath no fury like
a woman scorn so why wouldn't she take
half your stuff right yeah
um it's it's not guys don't take a
practical rational
woken approach to getting married they
usually just walk into a slaughterhouse
blindfolded because culture Society
religion
Disney movies everything that they've
grown up on and they're drunk on tells
them just you know just get married and
she'll be faithful and loyal and raise
your children and love you forever until
death do us part blah blah blah but for
most guys that's really not the case and
when you look at the stats and I covered
it in my book uh the unplugged Alpha
um
only 13 of people together over I think
it was 8.3 years was the average time
frame we're still in love and only three
percent of people were in a state of
bliss so so the chances of you living
out that state of bliss that they've
sold us you know like the marriage uh
contract the social contract of just
commit to her and she'll commit to you
and everything will be amazing the
chances of that happening are actually
quite small
um there's things that you can do to
manage that to improve the odds again
you know one of the things I was talking
about earlier is don't marry a don't
invite a promiscuous woman into your
life because very very simply I mean
you're going to have conflicts in a
relationship she's not going to like
something that you're doing or maybe
something that you say or a boundary
that you set and if she's been with a
hundred different guys or been in 50
different relationships or 40 different
relationships or whatever that happens
to be if she's been with a lot of men
the chances of her forming a healthy
monogamous parabon to you over long-term
basis diminishes massively with every
guy that she's been with this is
statistically proven a woman that's been
with a lot of guys that lost her
virginity at a young age is a terrible
choice for marriage but he doesn't talk
about that in his three lectures on
marriage he just says man up don't be a
[__] be a man you know take your vows
in front of people blah blah blah and
it's like okay that's interesting but
there's so many things that are that are
being missed here and unfortunately I
believe that that three-part series is
is going to ruin a lot of men's lives
but it is what it is right you know
people love that stuff yeah well to to
the problem with um with marriage so
when I when I was younger
I I had a real problem with marriage and
I think it was just you know Young
crazy you know driven 20 year olds Etc
you know we're all sort of anti-state in
some way shape or form so that was
generally my beef
um in the last couple years I've kind of
changed my opinion a little bit on it in
the sense that I think
modern culture and sort of the
liberalism that has emerged particularly
since you know once again adding a
little history here is like since the
days of the French Revolution and then
everything that sort of happened
particularly in the last 100 years with
you know women empowerment and driving
women into careers and all this sort of
[__] what's happened is that you know
men are no longer the um
you know the the the kind of the the
functional patriarchy that may have
existed before is gone and we're in a
situation where
you know
like I I actually find it stupid that
women are out there chasing careers I
actually think that that's a [__]
man's job uh yeah not something that's
and that's a new riddle a more newer
type of realization for me like there
was a good time in my 20s and even early
30s where I thought you know uh man and
a woman Twin Towers will conquer the
world together you know but you can't
have two people driving the car there
has to be one person in the passenger
seat and one person in the driver's seat
and traditionally and historically men
have generally LED and they've generally
had authority over their family but they
also had responsibility to their family
right they had they had the
responsibility to uh shelter to feed to
protect to provision to be competent to
solve problems they had all of these
responsibilities whereas women were more
responsible for
um you know taking care of the children
in the household and nurturing and
loving and caring and feelings and stuff
like that
um the problem is that today men still
have have responsibility to the
household State enforced especially if
there's a divorce but they have almost
no Authority in the household now the
authority in the household is the woman
slash the state this like if you get
divorced anybody that goes through the
divorce grinder in the west understands
how little control they have over their
life the government and their and their
soon-to-be ex-wife has almost all of the
control in that equation and they're
just a pleb
um they're like a dead fish you know
going Downstream with the current
basically they don't have much control
whatsoever it's it's kind of like hang
on for the ride and do the best that you
can and there's some strategies that I
talk to guys about with that as well too
when it comes to divorce but that's the
real problem is that men have authority
without or sorry men have responsibility
and when you have a situation like that
that's essentially slavery I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out